So who's excited about testing?
[CHEERING]
Excited?
Yeah.
OK, how many of you are
testing your apps already?
[CHEERING]
Is there anyone who is
not testing their apps?
[BOOING]
I don't believe you.
Unless your apps
are not working.
So, yeah, testing,
Android testing.
There's been a lot happening
during the past year,
past two years in
Android testing.
We've been getting better
and better at this.
There is now great support
in Android Studio and Gradle
to run your tests.
There is the Android
testing support library.
It's an unbundled library.
It's unbundled
from the framework.
You can update it with
a support library.
It's always fresh.
That's a good thing.
And one of the pieces of this
is Espresso, our UI testing
framework, which you probably
all know about, since you
are all testing your apps.
But that's the part that we're
going to concentrate on today.
So, yeah, Espresso-- just
a quick recap, quick intro
for maybe those of
you who are listening
on the live stream who are
not Espresso experts yet,
I want to discuss the
basic Espresso task flow.
So this is an app we
built a couple of months
ago for a code lab, for an
Android testing code lab.
It's a simple note taking app,
where you have a list of notes.
You can add a note,
add some text, save it.
That's pretty much it.
The thing is, this app is a
nice way of looking at tests
and explaining them.
Because UI tests seem
like a very human way
to test your apps.
You get the interface.
You look at it as if you
were looking at your phone.
And what do you do?
You first identify some view
you want to perform actions on.
So in this case, I
want to add a new note.
So I click the fab, right?
And then, on the
second screen, I
want to type some text in, save
the note, and then, finally,
verify if the note was added.
It's a simple thing, a very,
very human way to test an app.
And how does it look in code?
So Espresso has this
simple, really fluent API
that lets you express these
kinds of tests in an easy way,
in code.
So let's do a quick run-through.
So first of all, like I
said, we need to find a view.
And here we are looking for
a view with the ID addNote.
It's the fab.
When Espresso finds
the view, I want
to perform an action on it.
I want to click on it.
And then, on the second
screen, again, I'm
finding views, in this
case, the input fields,
and I'm performing
another action.
It's typeText.
So I'm typing text
into them again,
clicking on a fab
to save the note.
And here in this final.
last line of code, you see
things are a little bit
different.
I don't want to do
any more actions.
I want to verify the
result of my tests.
So instead of
performing an action,
I'm actually doing a check.
I'm trying to match
the note that I added,
if the text that I
added with the note
is actually displayed
on the screen.
So that's the basic
Espresso test.
And one nice thing
about Espresso
is, you might notice that,
apart from those basic building
blocks, these onView
calls, these viewMatches
and viewActions, and
assertions at the end,
there's nothing
really in between.
And that's the
magic of Espresso.
This is the whole point
of using this framework.
Notice how in the previous
test that I displayed,
we went through another
activity and back.
We went through three
different screens.
We performed typing.
We had to wait for the
screens to change, and finally
to display the final result.
But there was no code in between
to wait for those events.
That's Espresso.
But when people come from
different backgrounds,
from the different
testing frameworks, maybe,
and they try to use
Espresso for their apps,
I see a lot of questions
on Stack Overflow,
and answers that try to
work against that API.
So let's look at
something that I've
seen in answers on
Stack Overflow that
is not entirely correct.
So instead of working
with Espresso,
and using the constructs
that I've just
discussed, like viewMatches,
people usually ask a question,
"how do I get the view?"
How do I get that view object
to do things to it, to change
properties and verify things?
Well, you really shouldn't.
This is a very obscure API.
This is not meant
for you to use.
This will just not work.
The other thing that is a
little bit more dangerous
is getting the
activity and finding
stuff in the view hierarchy.
This line of code
would actually work,
but it's not really
what you want to do.
I mean, it will work as in it
will not throw an exception,
but again, this is
working against Espresso.
And one question for you--
this is something I've seen.
How many people think this
test will actually pass?
No?
Well, it will, because
it doesn't do anything.
OnView doesn't run any
real Espresso actions.
It just returns a
viewInteraction object,
which you can act upon next, and
cue actions, or do assertions.
This doesn't even look for
the view in the hierarchy.
So coming back at a
proper Espresso test.
Like I said, this just returns
a viewInteraction object.
And only when you
actually act on that,
this is where the
Espresso magic starts.
And so in this first part
of this presentation,
I just wanted to talk to you
a little bit about internals,
so that you have the
knowledge that will help you
in building your
tests, and finding
all the different scenarios,
and different ways
that your tests can fail.
So let's look at the
viewInteraction class.
This is source
code from Espresso.
It's open source.
You can go look it up.
You can open it yourselves.
You can dig into it.
I really encourage you to do it.
It's not that big, and it can
give you a better understanding
of what happens under the hood.
So when I perform an action
on the viewInteraction
object, this method,
doPerform, it's called.
And the first very
important thing that happens
is, it starts running
everything that it
does on the main thread.
So the test method
that you write,
it's actually on a
different thread.
If you want to work with views,
work with a view hierarchy,
we have to switch to
the main thread first.
Then this is a very,
very important thing.
UI controller is the most
important part of Espresso,
I would say.
This is an internal
class in Espresso
that has this method called
loopMainThreadUntilIIdle.
And this is where
all the magic happens
that I mentioned before.
This is the place where Espresso
waits for your app to be idle.
And I will discuss in a
second what it actually
means for your app to be idle.
And only then, only after
Espresso finds that it can run,
it can actually run
your actions safely
when the app is not
doing anything, will
it actually kick off
traversing the view hierarchy,
finding the view, and matching
it against your matter.
Only then.
And then, when it finds
the view, of course,
it performs the
action and passes it
into the UI controller.
So if you're writing
any custom actions,
you can use it again
instead of trying
to do things without Espresso.
So UI controller
loopMainThreadUntilIdle,
a long name, but--
So what it does?
It first sets up conditions.
It looks at AsyncTasks
in your app.
It also looks at AsyncTasks
from the support library, which
use a different thread pool.
So it needs to look
at both of those.
Then it looks at all
the idlingResources,
which is a custom
mechanism to tell Espresso
that your app is not idle, which
I will discuss in a second.
It sets up all these conditions,
waiting for all these things
to be idle, and then
runs another method,
which just loops and waits
until these conditions are met.
And what's important
in the end, it also
looks at the main looper.
The main looper is something
associated with your thread
that has a message queue.
So it basically looks
in the message queue
if there are any events that are
still pending, still preventing
Espresso from running safely.
And there is one common
misconception about this.
So if I have a handler that's
attached to the main thread,
so I'm posting to
the main looper.
If I post a message, post
a runnable that's delayed
500 milliseconds,
what do you think?
Is the app idle now, after I
run this line of code or not?
Who thinks the app is idle?
It's not, and you're right.
You must be really
advanced Espresso experts
since you came to this talk.
So when the queue is empty-- so
this is again part of Espresso.
This is part of a class that
looks at the message queue,
and determines if
it's safe to run.
So the first condition is
pretty straightforward.
If the queue is
empty, if there are
no events on the
main thread that
are waiting to be executed,
then, of course, we can run.
But then there is this
other part of the condition.
And what is this TASK_DUE_LONG?
Basically, it's a task that's
a long time in the future.
And if you look at
another piece of code that
looks at the queue state,
there's actually a constant
that we came up
with when working
with Espresso for a
long time, and testing
different scenarios.
And basically, we found
that if we look only
at messages in the message queue
that are up to 15 milliseconds
in the future, then this will
work for many, many scenarios.
So it's just one
thing to be aware of,
because that's a common
misconception I've seen online.
So if I post something
really far in the future,
Espresso can run.
And switching back
to idlingResource.
So idlingResource ia a pretty
simple but powerful concept
that you can use, if you
have long running operations
on different
threads in your app,
on threads that are not using
AsyncTask or AsyncTaskCompat,
because Espresso can
synchronize on those.
But if you have some kind
of network operation,
or some kind of
long computation,
something you have to wait
for until your app is actually
considered idle, you can just
implement this interface.
And again, it looks
pretty simple,
but lots of developers,
especially in the beginning,
and everyone is a beginner
at some point, of course,
people actually do a
lot of computation,
or figuring out if the app is
idle and in the isIdle method.
And I really encourage you to
make it as simple as possible.
This would be just
returning a Boolean flag
if your app is idle or not.
Don't call on transitionIdle
in the isIdle method.
Instead, when your app
actually becomes idle,
when your network
request finishes,
your computation
finishes, then remember
to call onTransitionToIdle
on the callback
that Espresso supplied to you.
Because that's really
telling Espresso "I'm
going to be idle now.
Check my state, maybe
Espresso can run now."
And I just want to mention
another powerful method
on the UI controller.
If you're ever writing
any custom interaction
and custom actions,
whenever you feel
like you want to
use threadSleep,
because you sometimes need
to pass between an event
that you want to happen,
don't use threadSleep, please.
Instead, use the construct
we give you in Espresso.
Use this method.
It sets up a condition.
It waits until the time
passes, and then, again,
with loopUntil, you get
all the same guarantees
about the message queue
about the app being idle.
So please use those
things if you're
doing more advanced stuff.
And moving on, in
the second part,
I just want to talk
to you about tips
and various pieces
of advice that I
gathered from internal teams of
Google working with Espresso.
Hopefully it'll help make
your test better, less flaky,
and maintainable.
So I'm going to go one
by one through them.
I mean, do you care about
your code structure,
your apps architecture,
your good quality
overall for your app?
Probably, yes.
Well, then, why
shouldn't you care
about the same for your tests?
Let me just show a very,
very simple example,
if you're still not convinced.
So with Espresso,
sometimes, you need
to code pretty close
to the implementation.
so for example, if
you use onData to look
for views in your adapter
views in a list view.
The simplest example
of this-- you
have a list view, an
adapter backed by map items.
And so you write
this line of code.
Your test passes,
and then you need
to use it in another test,
and another test, and so on.
So you copy paste it everywhere.
And then imagine you
change the adapter.
You change the data that's
backing your list view.
You're starting to use a
cursor, or whatever else.
And suddenly, you have
to go and change it
in every test in your code,
which is pretty daunting.
So instead, just try to
abstract away any more
complicated matters, any more
complicated pieces of code.
Again, this is very simple.
You can write your own robots,
or more sophisticated ways
to abstract away working
with screens in Espresso.
But then you just need
to change one place,
and your test will pass again.
Then one thing I want to stress
throughout this presentation--
please use the available
APIs and classes
that we give you in Espresso.
Use the available matchers.
We provide a lot of matcher
for pretty much every view
that's in the framework,
for most properties that
are in the framework.
And if something is missing,
then maybe we omitted it.
Maybe it should be there,
and it would be nice
if you find this
kind of situation
to please file a bug with us.
But on the other hand,
we can't know everything
about the custom views you make.
So definitely there are
moments when you would like
to write your own matchers.
And another instance
of that is if you
find that you are combining
lots and lots of matters
for your actions.
Maybe it's nice abstract
away this complexity,
and write a custom matcher,
compound matcher that
does that.
I just want to point out
that, again, there are classes
that will help you with that.
So for the simplest
matchers, you
want to just extend the
typeSafe matcher that
work on the onViews.
You don't have to do casting
and things like that.
This is very similar,
but if you want
to filter out just
certain types of views,
just subclasses of certain
views, use the bounded matcher.
Again, you will not have
to do the filtering.
You will not have to do
casting and matches safely.
You will just get the views of
the type that you care about.
Again, reuse.
we provide
countingIdlingResource.
Use it if you can.
You don't need to
write your own.
Many people try, again,
like I said, writing custom
idling resources.
They get tangled up in
those, where should I
call which method?
When am I idle?
And so on.
CountingIdlingResouce as
a very, very small API.
It's basically you call
Increment and Decrement.
So you call Increment before you
start a long running operation.
And you call Decrement
when it's ended.
And whenever the
counter is at 0,
so that means no long running
operations are running,
and Espresso can
consider it idle.
So please use it, if you
don't have a better reason
to write your own.
And on the topic
of idlingResources,
sometimes, for example,
when using counting,
when you use one kind of
idlingResource resource
for everything, you might
find that, in your app,
there are times when the app
is not idle for a long time.
And Espresso has some
sane defaults for timeouts
for such situations.
But if you find
that your app is not
idle for a really long
time, and it's actually
working as intended,
then you might have
to adjust the idling policies.
So there's an API for that.
If you have something that's
running for a really long time,
and you still want
that test to run,
then, you might
have to adjust that.
Next, pretty much
testing basics,
but focus on testing behavior,
not layout properties.
And still, a lot
of developers are
trying to use Espresso to
test the pixel perfectness
their layouts.
And while it's
technically possible,
it will make your tests
really unmaintainable.
So if you're trying to
assert that a certain view is
displayed at position
x and y and pixels,
and then you work with different
screen sizes and so on,
and then your designer
comes and tells you,
move that to the right, you
have to redo all your tests.
So please don't do that.
But at the same
time, if you really
want to check that a certain
view is displayed somewhere
on the screen relative
to another view,
we do provide
position assertions.
But they're relative.
They're easier to maintain.
If you just need to make
sure that a button is
next to a text
field or below it,
then you can use the
position assertions.
Write many small tests
instead of large ones.
And to explain this,
I like to think
about the whole
development process.
As you start with
working on single screens
and single features
of your app, you
start writing tests
for those single,
contained pieces of your
app, a single screen,
a single feature, then.
And these things, during
development, change a lot.
So you will go and redo your
tests, sometimes, and just
make everything work together.
But then, as your app gets
bigger and more mature,
it stabilizes as you're
close to release,
things are probably not
going to change that much.
You're going to
fix small details,
but the overall flow of
the app will not change.
And that's when you might start
getting longer user flow tests.
But just don't overdo it.
Again, the real value
is in the small tests
that test every screen,
every state of your app.
And on the same
page, launch directly
into the desired screen state.
So again, when testing
these self-contained screens
and states, launch
directly into them.
Don't do deep navigation before.
If you want to test
an activity that's
not the first
activity in our app,
and you need to traverse five
different screens to get there.
something can just
break along the way.
And then you're
not really testing
the thing you want to test.
You're getting errors about
something totally different,
totally another
part of your code.
So don't do deep navigation.
There's ways you can
easily achieve that.
So if you just override
the activity test rule,
you can override the
getActivityIntent method.
Just provide a custom intent.
If you have an activity
that gets some kind of data,
and then displays
a different state,
you can just provide
that data in the intent.
And just remember, if you use
this, every test in your class
will have the activity
started this way.
If you need some more
custom fine grained control,
just use the free
argument constructor.
And if you parse false
as the last argument,
the activity will not be
launched automatically
for your tests.
And then, in every test, you
can just prepare the intent
that you want.
And just remember you have to
launch the activity manually.
Most UI tests should be
as hermetic as possible.
So again, you want
to test your app.
You want to test the
screen of your app.
You don't want to test
the network conditions.
if the server is working.
You're testing the features that
you're coding inside your app,
and in your UI.
So make your test as
hermetic as possible.
There's tools that can
help you with that.
There's Espresso Intent.
There's Mockito for mocking.
Remember about dependency
injection, and Dagger 2.
And basically just
make sure you're
isolated from all the layers
that you don't care about.
Because that's not really
UI testing then, is it?
And speaking of
Espresso intents,
I don't know if
you've used it before.
It's a really nice thing
that we've added to Espresso.
It's a very small API.
Basically, it lets
you verify intents
that are sent from your app, or
stub the responses to intents
that you send to
other applications.
So here, in the
screen, you can see.
And before I'm setting up
response stubbing for an intent
that I sent out
to the camera app.
And below at the
bottom, I'm just
very verifying that
when I click the button,
my app sends out the intent.
I encourage you to use
it to isolate your test
from external applications.
Learn how to handle
long running animations.
That's been a common
problem in Espresso.
We try to synchronize on a
lot of things, like I said,
on AsyncTasks and so on.
But sometimes,
Espresso just simply
can't run because something
is keeps animating in your UI.
And there's two
types of animations I
want to call out, specifically.
So on the left, you can
see-- oh, it's not animating.
That's curious.
Oh, it's animating now.
Let's say you have
some kind of drawable.
It's your own.
It's your own animation.
You created it.
You control it.
It's all up to you,
if it runs or not.
And on the other hand,
you have animations that
are embedded in the framework.
So for example, a
progress bar is something
you don't really control.
It's just a system widget.
It animates, and there's not
much you can do about it.
And there's a way to actually
deal with the animations
that you control.
So for running
Espresso, anyway, we
tell you to disable
animations in the system.
So system wide, we disable
the layout animations,
transitions, and so on.
And you can actually
leverage that setting,
and read it in your
applications code,
and decide if the
animations are disabled,
maybe I should also
disable my own animations.
Because, really, that's
what the user said
when they adjusted the setting.
So it's the right
thing to do, anyway.
And on the other
hand, like I said,
some things, like
the progress bar,
are not very easy to work with.
So you have you will just have
to find other ways, like maybe
having a separate
flavor for your test
when the drawable
for that progress bar
is just not animated.
There are some
tools that can help.
So for example, in
developer tools,
you can switch a setting
called Show Surface Updates.
This might help you identify
some of those animations
that you were not aware of,
but are somewhere in your UI,
and keep posting events that
keep Espresso from running.
And next, how to
handle test failures.
So your test will
fail sometimes.
And it's obviously not intended,
but maybe the test is wrong.
Maybe you need to write
in some other way.
So the good thing
is, Espresso aims
to tell you exactly what
went wrong in the test,
and how to fix it.
So we have really
descriptive error messages.
We provide a message that
tells you what went wrong.
And moreover, we provide a
dump of the view hierarchy,
so you can look at the exact
views and their properties,
and maybe find the culprit.
But if that's not
enough, it's very easy
to implement your
own failure handler.
You can attach your own handler,
and just log out more data.
If you have some information
that you think would be useful,
you can just add it to the log.
One very interesting use of
that that I've seen online
is someone said that Espresso
was actually giving him
too much data about
the view hierarchy
for a very, very complex screen.
And so he created
a failure handler
that actually made
the logs smaller,
to only concentrate on the
parts that they care about.
It's an interesting use.
And then there's more
developer tools that
can help you with debugging.
So you can enable
showing touches,
pointer location, layer bounds.
Those basically let
you inspect better
what's happening on the
screen when Espresso runs.
And also use the
Hierarchy Viewer
if you just want to
interactively explore
the hierarchy, for example,
find out the IDs of views
or their relative positions
in the view hierarchy.
There's one more setting,
not in Developer Tools,
but in Accessibility.
So on some devices,
they're really slow,
or some emulators,
especially the older ones.
Single taps are not
registered correctly.
I mean single taps
coming from Espresso.
I don't want to go into
details, but we really
try to hide away the complexity
of actually simulating
a tap in Espresso.
But every tap is actually
two actions-- down and up.
And if a device is
really slow, if it's
bogged down by some kind
of background operations,
or the system is
just not keeping up,
these two operations can
happen too far apart.
And then the system
thinks it's a long press.
So basically, if you
change the delay to long,
that might help the situation.
And finally, enable testing
for Accessibility issues.
So that's something
many developers still
don't think about, sadly.
But really, you
want to make sure
that your applications are
accessible to all people who
want to use them.
And Espresso gives
you a very easy way.
Just enable the
Accessibility Validator.
It's a very easy way to
start testing for very
common Accessibility issues.
So please enable that,
and fix your apps,
fix your views to make sure
the app can be used by anyone.
And what's next?
I really encourage you to look
at the Espresso documentation.
There's a section called
Advanced Espresso, or Advanced
Sample, something like that.
And you will see lots and
lots of more tips and tricks
on how to use Espresso, how
to use the more unknown APIs
of Espresso.
Do check out the
Android Testing codelab.
It's not only about Espresso.
It's also about how to structure
your app to be more testable.
It gives a great overview
of all the testing
offerings that we have.
Finally, we have
greatest testing samples.
We have a testing blueprint.
And like I said before, remember
that Espresso is open source.
So if you find anyplace where
it's not working the best
it could, if we're missing
some kind of matchers,
if there's a source of
flakiness for your test
that we were not aware of,
file bugs, or better yet,
file pull requests, and help
us to make it even better.
[MUSIC PLAYING]